- You know every chick,
they're not cut out
to be a good prostitute,
you know what I mean?
Some of them were just hustlers,
or I train them to peel
tricks like a banana.
- Fast Money as soon as I step
on a concrete I'm catching
a date for 300, 700,
it just all depends.
Actually, I just recently
got robbed for $1100.
- You can spend all day with a whore,
and soon as you run out of money and dope,
she's gone to the next.
I was with this one girl,
I said, "What do you do?"
"I do everything", took me over to a spot,
next thing I know, my car got surrounded,
they broke out the
windows, ran into a fence.
It's dog eat dog.
- I have a female chest
developed through hormones,
and but I also have
male genitals down here.
If you see the pattern of what's going on,
there's several stages of evolution,
and I will reach the end
stage as a full dragon,
when I have all my procedures completed,
I will be a genderless dragon,
that's what dragons are.
- It is not expected to go to YouTube,
and amongst the options
to see a picture of a man
that has half his face blown off,
that's what happens when you
go to a particular channel,
which is called Soft White Underbelly.
Soft White Underbelly is produced
by a man called Mark Laita.
Let me explain who Mark Laita is.
He was a photographer from the age of 14,
but moreover and more
significantly, he grew up
to be a professional photographer,
working for advertisers
of great renown and success.
So he's done work for Apple corporation,
for BMW, for IBM, et cetera,
and the list goes on
the length of one's arm,
but he is also the producer
of the YouTube channel,
Soft White Underbelly,
that features people in America
who are not often heard.
Although he maintains
a studio in Manhattan,
and a studio in Los Angeles,
he has worked extensively
in Skid Row, but he has also
done work across America
in the 48 contiguous states.
The show that he worked on was
originally called Lower 48,
and it produced a book which
was called "Created Equal",
in fact, he wrote two other book, C-S-E-A,
and "Serpentine" his most recent book,
but most will know him
from his very disturbing,
and impacting and incredibly
effective channel,
again called Soft White Underbelly.
It is my great pleasure to welcome
to "Watching America", Mark Laita.
- Thank you.
- You started with
photography, you tell us
at the age of 14, you grew up
in Chicago, is that correct?
- I was born in Detroit,
but then at I think 10
years old moved to Chicago,
and I still consider myself a Chicagon,
even though I've been living
in LA for decades now.
- Okay, White Sox or Cubs?
- Detroit Detroit Tigers.
(laughing)
- Okay.
- I'm Tigers fan, but I love my bears.
- Okay, well, what are your parents like?
I always like to know
people's point of origin.
- That's a great question.
Both my parents were Lithuanian,
and my mom was born in Lithuania,
my dad was born in Chicago,
but then moved to Lithuania
during the depressed,
the end of the depression and
then moved back to Chicago,
or actually moved back to
Detroit, that's where they met,
and had me and my sister eventually,
and we grew up in
Detroit and then Chicago.
And I left Chicago, and
moved to LA when I was 26,
but my parents, my mom
just passed away recently.
- I'm sorry.
- They were married forever, obviously,
and my dad's 91, I believe now.
So my childhood unlike a lot
of the people I interview,
was pretty great.
It wasn't perfect, my dad
and I butted heads a lot
when I was younger, but no longer,
and my mom was like, I could
do no wrong in her eyes,
and that was, that to me is about as good
as it gets for a kid.
- I'm not trying to compound your pain,
but I remember when my mother died,
and I've spoken to many people
about the same experience,
one has this peculiar feeling
of being left on the planet.
They depart, we remain,
and it causes us to look
at things differently.
Have you found that to be true?
- No, honestly, I'm ashamed to admit,
I was super close with
my mom, very, very close,
and she passed away at
the very end of January,
and I honestly believe
I've been burying myself
in this project, which I do
anyway, that's my nature,
when I work, I work like a maniac,
but I've been so busy with this project
that I almost haven't had time to grieve.
I haven't allowed myself to,
so it's like I'm just
protecting myself from it.
- Understand, well, that's
an interesting thing,
because people in this
realm who deal with it,
counselors and what have you,
say there is no right way to grieve,
we all do it differently
in how we want to,
that doesn't mean that that's any measure
of your indifference, as you say,
or lack of love for
your mother, it's just-
- Oh not at all, it's the opposite.
- Yeah, it's just your coping mechanism.
Okay, well, I'm at that momentous moment,
when somebody placed a
camera in your hands,
I should explain that I'm also
a communications professor,
I teach cinematography in filmmaking,
and I've taught photography,
still photography.
- Oh great.
- And I always ask
my students, "When was the first time
"somebody placed to come in your hand?"
Now today of course,
everyone has that as a phone,
so all the kids today will have had it.
Do you remember when
somebody placed a camera
in your hands for the first time?
- Yeah, as a kid, I was
always drawing and painting,
that's all I did,
and at one point, I picked up a camera,
my dad's 35 millimeter camera,
and I started taking
some photos of little,
of similar things that I did
with my still life career,
when I was an advertising photographer,
leaves and flowers and animals,
and I just took to it instantly.
I just loved photography,
I loved how it was
part a scientific document of
whatever you pointed your camera at
and then it could also be an artistic
interpretation of that.
It was it was art, but it was
also science at the same time,
and I loved that,
and I never put never the
camera down ever again.
- So was it a progression
of going from a brownie
to a Nikon, a Canon to a
Leica, I mean, was it fast?
- No it was, what was it?
I think was a Cowa flex,
my dad's camera that I borrowed,
and he just let me have it,
and then at one point,
this was one of the most important things
that ever happened to me.
I had a cheap Canon camera, I think,
or I can't remember what
kind of camera I had,
but it was, it was very
clear that I was serious
about photography,
and my dad took me to Helix Camera,
which is the big camera
store in Chicago at the time,
and the salesmen are showing
me the cheaper cameras,
the 81, and the this, whatever,
and that's what I kind of
figured that that'll work,
that does a trick for me.
- Yes.
- And my dad goes, he looked
at all the whole range,
and there was a there was F1,
which was the top of the line,
the Cadillac of Canon cameras,
and they were all the cheaper ones,
and I was happy with the cheapest one.
My dad goes, "You're
serious about this, right?"
Sorry, I get emotional.
And I go, "Yeah" he
goes "Let's get the F1"
- Wow, what a gift. I mean,
in more ways than one,
what a gift to have a
father with that insight.
- It makes you take, it makes you respect
what you're doing, it makes
you take it very seriously.
- Yes.
- And you put more belief
and energy behind it.
You take it seriously,
and that was a big deal.
- Do you think you were intended,
if one has a sense of
destiny, you may not,
but do you think you will
always somehow intended
to be a photographer?
- No, I just think it's what you're,
I'm not big on that kind of thinking,
I just think I'm very visual.
I've always been very visual,
my mom was very visual,
my mom and I are very similar,
and it just that's the way I'm wired,
and I could be wired to be a
mathematician, or whatever.
I mean, I've always kind of
understood this on some level,
but I heard Richard Branson from Virgin,
talking about career choices,
trying to figure out what you
want to do with your life,
and he said, I'm paraphrasing,
but I think he said "You make four lists,
"one is everything you're good at,
"make a list of everything you're bad at,
"make a list of everything you love,
"and a fourth list of everything you hate.
"If you look at that list,
"it will tell you exactly what to do"
and I realized, especially
with this project,
with the Soft Underbelly
portraits and interviews I'm doing
it's exactly that.
- Well let's start with that.
Let's talk about that specifically.
One of the things that strikes me
is that to do this kind of work,
and I have to remind the audience
we have said this at the
outset, I will say it now,
because it bears repeating.
At the outset of this program,
you heard our senior
producer, Gina Gumbony,
warn the audience that this material
may not be suitable for everyone.
Some of you may think that
we were speaking strictly
of children, or sensitive persons,
we're speaking of adults too.
So we're going to go into areas,
and territory that many
people might find unsettling,
and so we say that with some
forewarning for those of you
who may not want to go where we
are going to go in this
particular program.
Mark, you have spoken
just a little while ago
about the kind of distancing that you need
to do sometimes emotionally,
you throw yourself
into projects to be
able to get things done,
and to kind of keep them emotions at bay.
There's a curiosity in
I think, a similarity,
by you having to take
somewhat the same approach
to your work, so just to
remind people just joining us,
I'm speaking with Mark Laita.
He has a channel on YouTube,
which is very disturbing for some people,
enlightening for others,
but hopefully motivated
for the purpose of
helping to change society,
if not the lives depicted,
then future generations.
He has interviewed typically
people in Skid Row,
and elsewhere who are
prostitutes, sex workers, pimps,
alcoholics, people who
are addicted to heroin,
various forms of heroin,
people who have been sexually abused,
people who have been victimized,
people with rather
aberrant and unusual views
such as KKK, Grand Wizards.
The array is far more widespread
than people might suspect
just looking at just
one hand of the channel.
You are dealing with people whose lives
are predominantly for
the most part wrecked.
How did you start to come up with the idea
of inviting people into your
studio, putting a light box up
with soft diffused lighting,
shooting straight on,
and then from a three quarter angle
from the side and making these videos?
- I've always been doing portraits.
I mean, even when I was like
a teenager back in Chicago,
I would go down to the
Chicago's equivalent of Skid Row
in Los Angeles, the West Side,
near West Side of Chicago,
where you would have all
the homeless alcoholics
at the time, just sitting on the street.
And it was fascinating,
growing up in the suburbs,
and coming from a middle-class
family where everything was,
our home life was normal
and no traumatic events,
no craziness and I would
see these homeless guys,
I was just like, wow, this
is what a different world,
and I was fascinated by it,
and I would do portraits of them.
And throughout my career,
I kind of played with that,
I would do my advertising
where it was very slick,
and polished, and I'm making iPhones,
or computers, or cars, or
cosmetics look really great,
but I always had this other
side of me that I loved,
which was my fascination
with these darker subjects
that are usually people.
In "Created Equal" my first
book, was exactly that
I decided to go to every state,
in each of the lower 48 states,
and do portraits of
everything from Cowboys
to astronauts, to polygamists,
to repo men, to everything
you can imagine,
and so that was the beginning
of Soft White Underbelly,
and so after Created Equal ended,
after that book was published,
and we had some shows, and
it was kind of like, okay,
let's close the door on that.
I didn't know quite what
my next move would be
with my personal work,
advertising was still continuing,
I was still going full bore with that,
but my personal work, I just
didn't know quite what to do,
and I thought the Skid Row
down in LA is very interesting,
and it's right here, not
too far from where I live
in my studio in LA and
I got another studio
just to shoot portraits
of people on Skid Row.
And I did that for a
while, did that for years,
started in 2010, and got some
really interesting subjects,
but they were just portraits,
and as Create Equal,
Created Equal is just a portrait,
you don't get to hear the person,
you don't get to hear their life story,
you don't get to know anything about them,
your imagination can fill in those blanks,
but sometimes you're just
guessing at what the story is.
And then at some point Canon,
the Canon camera company
came out with cameras
that did video on as well
as still photography,
and I had one of these cameras,
and I just started to
shoot a video, or two.
An interview of some of the people
that I was photographing,
that I got to know,
and I did an interview
with a heroin addict
prostitute named Caroline,
and it was the most
heartbreaking thing ever.
Wow, that was powerful.
I just got lucky that
first time I thought,
and then I did a second
one was somebody else,
and a third, and a fourth and a fifth,
and I'm like Jesus,
there's a lot of interesting stories here.
And I should have just
continued with that,
but I got divorced,
and just my life got
turned upside down a bit,
and I put it down for a while.
Turn the clock forward, I'm
currently building a house,
and I had to put all my furniture,
and all my belongings
basically in storage units,
so I had four different storage units
across the city of LA,
and like why am I paying all
this rent, storage unit rent,
I should get one big storage unit,
store all my furniture in one place,
and maybe have a studio up front to shoot
and if that was allowed on Skid Row
that would be killing
two birds with one stone.
So I looked around on Skid Row,
and I found a really great place.
It's right in the middle of the actions,
which is good and bad.
It's good and that people
will walk right by,
and feel very free to
just step in for a moment,
make a little bit of money
and tell their story,
and they feel free to walk right out.
They don't have to go upstairs,
they don't have to go up an elevator,
they don't feel trapped at all,
and I started that around March of 2019,
and I enjoyed it so much,
I just kept with it,
I just kept going and kept going.
It was like the more he did
it, the more I enjoyed it,
the more I felt like I was onto something,
and I remember when I first
started putting the videos
up on YouTube, I said no
one's gonna watch this.
I put them up on YouTube just
to kind of show my friends
have a way to show friends,
some crazy videos that I shot,
and I thought literally, I'll get 20,
or 30 people subscribing
to this craziness,
and it grew and it grew and it grew,
and next thing I know, very quickly now,
I think it's a million, 1.3 million now.
So it took off.
- You have been the
recipient of some criticism.
I'll mentioned the first one
and I don't do this with glee,
but just to be fair about
the issues you've raised.
The first one is that in general,
you're exploiting people,
you pay people who are
sleeping on the sidewalk
in tents, 20 or $40 to
get them to speak to you,
people who evidently are
slightly more endangered
by revealing who they are,
because they have pimps
controlling them, or what have you,
you'll pay as much as $100.
- No, your numbers are inaccurate, but-
- Oh okay, all right, well
what are the accurate numbers?
- A pimp is not going to
admit to human trafficking
on a platform like YouTube for $500,
he's just not, he's not a fool.
- Okay.
- And a guy who frequents
prostitutes and is married
is not gonna come on my channel,
and talk about exactly what he does
for a little bit of money.
They're just not, it's gonna
cost a lot of money, so yeah.
- We're talking Ks here or hundreds?
- I don't want to give out my numbers,
but it's a lot more than
people anticipate, or imagine.
- So the argument that's made Mark though,
is that you're paying
people to divulge things
about their life and they sign a waiver.
You've heard this before, it's not new,
and they sign a waiver of disclosure,
and the argument that's made by some,
although there are others
who rally to your defense,
I hasten to add, they will say,
well he's just benefiting
from people talking
about their lurid experiences,
and people vicariously
getting a thrill out
of hearing about other people's misery,
and there are others who as I've said,
rally to your defense and
say "No, he's actually
"conveying dignity to these
people by paying them,
"and saying, look, your time is valuable,
"and you could be turning
a trick in a car on a tent,
"or something, but I'm gonna pay you
"for your time, as well".
So how do you respond to the criticism?
- Well, there's a lot of
things I could say about that.
One is that,
first of all, let me preface
the whole thing with like
is Christmas the celebration
of the birth of Jesus Christ?
or is it a marketing
opportunity for retailers?
- Both.
- It's both, everything is both.
Are hotels exploiting the fact
that you need sleep tonight?
They're exploiting you,
because you need sleep tonight,
or they're just a nice place to stay,
so it really has a lot to
do with your perspective.
If you want to see somebody
who's doing something evil,
and dark, then you can see
this as exploitive, for sure.
Absolutely, it's photography
and storytelling,
but just the nature of those
is exploitive, it just is.
There's no way to take
a photo of somebody,
you're exploiting a pretty girl,
when you're putting her in a cosmetics ad.
- Right and in your
turn, I have to say that
someone could accuse us of exploiting you,
about exploiting other people.
- Yeah, I mean, exploiting
somebody is just like,
Shelby Lee Adams is a photographer
that does portraits of Appalachian people,
where he grew up, he's
a fine art photographer.
He got accused of some
similar kind of things.
I heard him say once, "The
reason people will see this
"as exploited is because there's so"
the majority of the people
watching my channel,
or looking at his work,
are probably middle class,
or upper class people,
and it's so disconcerting,
so disturbing, so unsettling
to look at this stuff
that you wanna blame somebody.
- Right.
- It's too much the process,
the human mind can't go,
wow, this is really horrible,
this is terrible that
this exists in our world.
The human mind can't process it all,
so you wanna blame somebody.
And the easy target is the
photographer that shot it.
It's just like, there he is, blame him.
He's exploiting these
people, end of story.
- Absolutely, yeah.
- And that's a very knee
jerk simplistic reaction,
and I get it, but the
people that I interview,
every single one of them,
virtually every single one,
maybe a couple exceptions
out of 2000 people
I've interviewed, love it,
and they wanna come back,
and do a second time,
or a third time, or a fourth time,
and they view me as some kind
of therapist angel down there.
- It's cathartic.
- Yeah, it's, so many of
the people I've interviewed,
said they've never shared
these stories with anyone,
and I mean, I've had a handful
of people that came up to me,
and said, "You know I
haven't used my drugs
"since I've talked to you
"that was the best thing I ever did,
"when can I do it again?"
They don't even wanna
be paid the second time,
they just wanna come back.
- Well, before we go much further,
I'd like to play a clip
so the audience can get
at least more of a taste
of exactly what's going on.
So the first person which I alluded to
at the outset of this show today,
was this very arresting image of Jerry,
who has half his face blown off,
he has one remaining eye
which doesn't function fully.
They've basically the surgeons
through 24 hour periods
of surgery we are told,
basically reformed skin.
- He works, he's a machinist
for aerospace company
coming home from work at a bus stop,
and he didn't even know, he
didn't see anything happen.
Next thing you know he
woke up three months later
in a hospital.
- Wow.
- But somebody walked up to
him with a shotgun point blank
and just shot him inside of the head.
- Well, let's hear him speak,
and also at the same time,
it's interesting a part
of the clip I want to show is that,
he doesn't seem to have
directed animosity or hatred,
amazingly, let's play
that clip, here we go.
- I was in a bus stop going
home from work one day.
A couple of months later,
I woke up in the hospital.
I thought I was dreaming.
A doctor told me, that I was
shot in the side of the head
with a shot gun and he said
the only reason I survived,
because it was point blank range.
He said if it was not point blank range,
my head would of been out on the street
and see I can see again with the left eye,
my (indistinct) I could not
smell or breathe at all,
and the skin they said,
your brains was hanging out your head
like a (indistinct) hanging out my face
and they had to remove it.
I said to the nurse, I
haven't looked at myself
for over two years, I just
gotta accept that you know,
and keep moving on.
- That was quite astonishing to hear,
it's very difficult
sometimes to understand him.
You do use subtitles or captioning
under your videos but we used clips
we hope your audience could grasp.
- Jerry's a little bit
difficult to understand.
- How did you meet him?
- Jerry was panhandling,
right at the edge of Skid Row
at the Flower mart, so in Los Angeles
they have this big area that's nothing but
wholesalers selling to florists shops
and the general public can
go there on certain days
and buy flowers for weddings
or whatever they want.
And Jerry would panhandle there,
he would just sit there
with a tin can and shake it,
shake the money in his can and
people would give him money.
It was the first time I saw him,
I was just like, Jesus,
this is the saddest thing I've ever seen.
- And when you approached
him and spoke to him,
was he receptive, I mean?
- Oh very friendly, in fact
when I first walked up to him
I told him what I was doing and he said
" Yeah sure let's go right
now" I said "Come on"
and I took him to my
studio, we talked in the car
and he's very friendly,
he's just delightful
to talk to and..
- He's a really sweet man.
- Super sweet.
He and I, like I show up
and he just wants to talk
basketball, he loves to
talk about NBA basketball
and he's just the
friendliest, kindest person
you have ever met, you can feel
when you're just in his presence.
- So Mark I have to ask you
about the technical aspects,
so you're going into your studio,
this is one of your
first interviews early on
back in the day.
You've got your diffusion set up
and you decide to shoot
him, did you feel awkward?
Or perhaps not, one doesn't
have to feel this way.
Did you feel awkward, if
there was there ever a moment
where you felt I might
be exploiting someone,
if at all you entertained that idea?
- No.
- I would imagine that
Jerry would be the case
with half his face missing.
- No that thought has
never entered my brain.
One thing I learned and
this is interesting,
I was doing portraits in New York City
I used to do them all over
the country for Created Equal
but then after that I just
started doing more and more,
I was doing them in Manhattan once
and I was with my assistant, Axel
who's worked with me for decades
and I was just picking up, all
kinds of interesting people
in Manhattan and Manhattan
has tons of interesting
characters on the street right?
I would pick up whoever
was just interesting
walking down the street
and ask them, tell then what I was doing,
almost everyone would
come upstairs with me,
up to the sixth floor of
a building on Broadway
near Union Square, my assistant goes,
"It's amazing how everybody trusts you.
"Like everybody trusts
you to come upstairs",
Manhattan has some of
the most beautiful women
in the world, and I would just,
she might have an interesting story,
so I would just walk up to her,
if I was a guy looking to date the girl,
I might, there'd be
different body language
and my voice would get tight, or whatever,
things that happen like that,
but in this case because
I knew, subconsciously
my motives were pure.
- Yes.
- I knew that was I was
doing was a good thing,
for her and for me and for everyone.
- So they read that.
- People can sense that, and he says,
"How are you getting the most
beautiful women on the planet
"to just go up a sixth floor with you?
"They don't even know who you are,
"and you're much bigger than them"
I'm six four.
"You're much bigger than they are,
"you could overpower them
easily and they come up gladly"
And I realized that wow, what is that?
Why is if, I was asking her out on,
for her phone number or something,
it would probably play out differently,
but because I'm doing this,
they just easily agree
and I think it's because
of what I just said, which is,
I knew that what I'm doing.
- Has value.
- I'm respecting them, I'm honoring them
and they can sense that,
they can sense that I'm not
up to no good, it just flows from there.
- Well let's hear a female voice, Pamela.
A certainly more recent
person you interviewed.
Pamela is a prostitute,
she reveals that she
only went to the seventh grade,
she was molested by an uncle
witnessed a lot of violence,
has at various times had
to jump out of vehicles
and horrifically saw her friend run over
and in this clip she talks
about a variety of things.
You ask her about the
most unusual type of thing
a client has asked her
to do and she tells us.
You're listening to Watching America,
I'm your host Doctor Alan Campbell,
my guest is Mark Laita and
I must remind the audience
that this is an extremely mature program,
as has been forewarned
at the outset of the show
by our producer Gina
Gambony, a senior producer
Gina Gambony.
If you are inclined to
find things offensive,
disturbing, then I
would strongly recommend
you don't listen to the
remainder of this program.
But here we go now,
with the voice of Pamela
as interviewed by Mark Laita.
- 14 I got kidnapped by a pimp,
this one guys crush
fetish, he just wanted me
to step on a muffin and you know smash it
in the sidewalk, like this,
he gave me 800 dollars to do that
and one of my wife-in-laws got killed
and she got killed and I found her
in the middle of the street dead
and it like blew my mind
so when I did heroin
it numbed me, I didn't
have to feel the pain.
I felt like I was back
in my mother's womb.
When we went back to pick her up,
she was just laying in the
middle of the street dead,
with her head busted open
and like every ounce of blood
drained out of her body.
I've had to jump out of
cars, going 40 miles an hour
50 miles an hour, I've been
beat with clothes hangers
I've never seen my son.
Well I seen him when he was two months old
and my middle son, 10 days old
and my girl she was 10 months.
- Now some people would say,
I understand I think why you do it,
but some people would say,
well why do you have to ask
questions about their daily routine,
sex workers, and you say?
- Well first off it's interesting,
it's an interesting
aspect of what they do,
I'm not interviewing insurance agents,
talking about how they shuffle papers
and work numbers all day,
I'm talk talking with a prostitute
and what they do is sometimes-
- Wait are you saying double
indemnity isn't interesting?
- I just think these are
very interesting lifestyles
that I'm documenting and
to not ask those questions
kind of leaves the whole thing like,
anyway I still get people that
go, "I wish you'd asked this"
or, "I wished you'd asked that"
and at some point you need
to feel out the subject
and figure out what you can get away with
and what's going to be disrespectful
or what's going to make them uneasy.
But with Pamela she was and
most people I interview,
they're pretty open, it's
almost like they've been asked,
they've never shared these
things and to be asked
in this kind of environment,
is they're willing to share everything.
- Do you feel ever
depressed, when you have
say I was going to say a young born,
but there's a lot of older women too,
who come off the street,
they've been servicing customers
come right to you,
they're drinking a Sprite
or whatever it is, they do their interview
and you know they're
returning to that world.
Do you ever just want
to reach out and say,
"How can I help this person?
"What can I do?"
Now I know that you have
actually, by your own estimation
given about 150 thousand dollars away
and invested in people.
- Yep.
- How do you handle that
one when they're going to
descend the stairs from your studio
and you know they're
going to go right back to
how they've lived?
- Yeah that's the case in almost all,
of the people I've talked to.
It's a really difficult situation
and most people I don't
think could stomach it.
I think it gets, it can be so draining,
and so, you're just so defeated
and there's nothing you
could do to save this person,
if you wanted to.
You would get taken down,
before they're gonna get saved.
If I was totally going to help someone,
you end up, let's say you're
gonna start paying their rent
or giving them money,
they're just gonna use
the excess money for
whatever their addiction is.
You have to understand and I learned this
in the first like eight years
of being down there shooting
down on Skid Row, that
a lot of these people
are not helpable.
You can't help them.
They're not even willing,
they're not interested in being helped.
Even though they might say
in the interview, you know,
I get a lot of people saying,
"I just I just want some help
"and I wish somebody would
just do this for me do that"
You have to understand
that those are words
and it's almost like the way I see it now,
'cause I've taken to
most people earlier on,
I be like oh my god, you just
need this, that and the other.
So I would give them
this, that and the other
and that costs a lot of money
and I realized what I was
doing is just enabling them
to continue doing what they're doing.
- How do you differentiate
between those who are lying
and those who are not?
There are some cases, and
it's a very interesting
array of videos.
Just to remind the audience,
you're listening to
Watching America. I'm Dr. Alan Campbell
and Mark Laiter is my guest.
He is a very successful
photographer with studios
on both coasts, one Manhattan one LA,
done a lot of commercial
work for IBM, BMW,
for Apple, you name it, he's done it,
high gloss, high style photography,
has been the recipient of awards,
has had private shows,
has written three books,
Created Equal, Sea and Serpentine
and has his own dedicated
channel on YouTube,
which is called Soft White Underbelly.
On those shows Mark, the segments,
you will at sometimes say
something to the effect of
and I'm paraphrasing.
After years of hearing people speak,
I've learned to recognize
untruths and what have you.
And in other persons that speak,
you seem to be neutral and
not sure and accepting,
how have you learned or
have you learned in fact,
maybe it's a skill that's never developed,
to differentiate between the authentic
and those who are just simply
going for sympathy narrative?
- Yeah, sometimes it
becomes hard to decipher
what is truth and what is made up
and I'm sure, it's just the
nature of telling a story.
If you if you and I were speaking
about our old school days
and the teacher that was
a monster that we had
when we were in eighth grade or whatever,
back in high school, you
embellish those stories
and you make the gym teacher
seem more evil than he was
and everything gets exaggerated,
so there's plenty of that
going on with these stories.
But there have been
some where they're just
totally concocting stories
and I've even been fooled
a few times that I put up those stories
and then their their parents
contact me or their siblings
and say, "That's all BS"
and I do a little homework
and find out that yes,
that's totally untrue
and I delete the video.
There's one or two, there's
one that I've left up
with a explanation saying
this is totally a lie.
I've spoken to the family-
- That's the one I'm referring to yes.
- Sara I think her name is.
- Yeah Sarah, right.
- I lost my daughters and
my husband last summer
in a house fire, I've never been drunk.
My husband got really
you know, he stayed home.
He never had a job in his
life, he was using drugs,
I found out about crystal
meth, he was slamming it.
And he actually was slamming in his neck,
when I caught him with drugs
and a significant amount of money,
I had around 140,000 in the bank
and I was down to like nine grand.
And when I realized this first time ever,
he usually the longest ever was six days,
he left me tied up in the bathroom.
And he was putting cigarettes out on me,
I have over 100 I'm all over my body.
I have holes, some of them
took over a year to even heal.
My kids this year, would
have been 20, 18, 15 and 13.
So and they just died last summer.
Their father set their beds
on fire while they were asleep
and he stabbed me five
times and he killed himself.
- She was just so like, convincing,
that it's like really the
first time I really got fooled.
And you know, maybe
one day I'll delete it,
but for now it's still up there.
- And no, I think it
actually serves a purpose.
I find me as an outsider
say it gives perspective
and balance, so it's actually warranted.
When people are signing
waivers to allow you
to use their imagery, don't
you have a professional problem
in that many of these
people are using aliases
to begin with, and they
are highly spurious,
questionable personalities,
so how do you handle that?
- Well I tried to get IDs,
but a lot of people don't have IDs.
- Yeah.
- And you just, if somebody
comes back to me and says,
"Oh, this is a problem" or whatever,
then I'll take the video
down, but that's happened
like once or twice, hasn't really come up.
But technically, I'm sure
there's more than a handful
of cases where I'm putting up a video
and this model release they've signed
is not really their real name.
And I don't think anybody's
ever gonna come back to me
and say that's wasn't me or
that you know, whatever so.
- Well, I'm eager to leave
actually the idea of people
faking you out, but there's
one story I have to allude to,
which I'm sure you can imagine is Kelly.
- Have you had contact
with your mom or anybody?
- No.
- So you're just on your own.
- I don't have anybody, nobody, but God,
that's why I have to sell,
prostitute just to get by
and on the county, that's
all I have is the county
and my tent and God
and tricks, that's all I
have, nobody checks on me,
nobody calls my government phone,
I don't know who my dad is,
I just try to be strong 'cause,
and I'm just trying to keep it together
because I don't want to be out
here for the rest of my life,
I really don't.
- You received criticism because you had
great deal of empathy
and sympathy for her,
and you set up a Go Fund Me fund
and your intention was
not to give her the money,
to go back to school and to
there was X amount of dollars
which I think was around nine thousand
or something like that.
- No it ended up being 28 thousand.
- It wound up being 28 thousand
and then there was some suit sayers,
sitting at home on the
couches and their armchairs
watching the interview and saying
"There are things here that don't add up"
and then I believe it
was the Washington Post
that got involved and some
others have written about this,
that it was then questionable
about your motivations
and then suddenly you
were looked at askance
with disfavor, how did you handle that
and have you fully recovered
from that whole episode?
- Yeah my little joke is
that none of my videos
are fully uploaded until some
commenter says they're lies.
- It's a prerequisite.
- Virtually every single video I put up,
somebody comments, oh this person's lying
and the interesting thing about Kelly,
her real name is Kiera,
but here's what happened,
I post a video every day,
pretty much, sometimes two a day
and Christmas Eve I was
shooting, down at Skid Row
and this gang member that I know brought
his girlfriend I guess and said
"You wanna talk to this girl"
and I was driving away with my equipment,
I was leaving for the day, I was like
"See ya later, I'm gone"
he goes "No, no, no talk to this girl"
I looked at her, she looked
like she was 12 years old
and I'm like all right, so I pull over
and she tells me her story a little bit
just to give me a 30 second
version and I'm like okay,
let me back up and I'll set up again
and I'll shoot one more.
And it turned out to be this
really heartbreaking story,
one of the most powerful
on my channel I would say
and I edited it that night
and I put it up on Christmas day,
I wasn't going to put
anything on Christmas day,
'cause my content is
so dark, I just figured
it wasn't appropriate but her story was,
it was certainly dark,
but it was kind of like,
beautiful at the same time.
So I put it up on Christmas day, morning
and then initially get a
really strong reaction,
people were heartbroken over her story,
and then she calls me back
four or five days later
and says "Can you take it down,
"my family's giving me a hard time"
And I'm like "Okay sure"
so I deleted her video,
even though it was
great and then two more,
two three weeks later
she calls me up and says,
"You know what?
"Forget my family, my family's
never done anything for me,
"they've never been there for
me, put the video back up,
"just use my street name"
'cause the reason I posted
the video with her real name
which is Kiera and she
said "Use my street name
"which is Kelly" so I
put it up the second time
with Kelly and then got
to know this girl by then.
I saw that she was
working Figueroa Street,
which is a street in Los Angeles
where all the prostitutes,
I mean unbelievable
amount of prostitution
going on in that street.
So has the rest record, all
the girls down there know her,
so there's no doubt that
she was a prostitute.
She claims that she never
went to high school,
but the Washington Post
reporter looked up the fact
that she had registered for high school
but then Kiera says that she
did register for high school
but she never went, she
went for like two days
and then never went.
And she was in the foster system,
she says she was at six years
old, the Washington Post
said it was five years old,
so parts of her story are not 100% proven,
but whether she went to high
school or not, doesn't matter,
whether she was in the foster
system at five years old
or six years old, doesn't matter,
the fact that this girl was
working Figueroa Street,
as a prostitute, getting arrested,
living that super dangerous lifestyle
and a fairly lucrative lifestyle.
I mean these girls say they make
500 to 1000 dollars or more a day, a night
and everyone says they're lying,
but I believe those numbers aren't,
they're exaggerated I'm sure,
but they're not greatly exaggerated.
They're not making $75 dollars a night,
they're making easily several
hundred dollars a night
and a lot more for some
She gave that up, she
chose as a 22 year old girl
to give that up and just
try to start a new life,
without anyone's help,
no family, no nothing,
no money.
Yes she had braces, yes
she had fingernails,
yes she had nice clothes,
'cause that's what these girls
have, they all have that,
if you look at all these
girls, they all have nice hair
and nice clothes and
fingernails and all that,
'cause they make good money, tax free.
So she gave that all up to
start a new life at 22 years old
without an education and that's remarkable
and I saw that she was doing this,
I saw that she wasn't
going back to her old ways
after I took the video down
and before I put it back up.
So when she told me I
could put it back up,
I said this person deserves some help.
I'm gonna try this Go Fund Me thing,
I'd heard about it, I'm
gonna try my first Go Fund Me
with this girl.
So I posted her video with
the link to the Go Fund Me
and in two days it generated 28 thousand,
29 I think, Go Fund Me
takes a percentage so,
$29000 in two days.
It was actually 30000 but what happened is
on that second time
the video got uploaded,
again it got lots of views,
and lots of empathetic
compassionate, concerned commenters,
as soon as the word got
out that her Go Fund Me
was a wild success, then all
of a sudden everything flipped.
And all these comments
saying she was lying,
it's all made up, it's all whatever,
here's a picture of her mom's Facebook
with her and her mom,
here's a picture of her
grandmother with her,
it's all a lie.
She's getting a nice break
that no one else was getting right?
So I think that created
this, all these claims
of her story being fake,
because if I'd never done
a Go Fund Me for her,
her story's identical
to everyone else's on my channel.
If you watch all the prostitute videos,
they're all basically
the same exact story.
There are some details that are changed,
one worked with a pimp
when she was 14 years old,
and the other met a pimp when she was 16
and one little details are different.
- The typical scenario seems to be,
very often that there's
a mother or father,
have substance abuse,
there's a menacing uncle or father
that physically abuses
them, they run away,
they drink a lot, they do weed,
then they progress to something else,
then they get caught up in the system,
they go work for a pimp, then
they go into a foster home,
then they're out of there again.
I had a personal experience,
I wasn't planning on sharing
this, but I will right now.
When I lived in San Francisco,
I lived there for 11 years
and I came in contact, it
was brought to my attention,
a young woman who was a prostitute,
she was a heroin addict and
I was very, very aggrieved
by seeing that she had track marks
and everything was working
and she had a pimp.
She finally wound up in San
Francisco City Hospital,
in many locations, you don't
want to be in the city hospital
I went and saw her and I said,
"If I were to be able
to find a way for you
"to be able to kick this, would you really
"be willing to do that?"
She said "Yes", I worked fervently pulling
every contact I had in San Francisco
and I managed to find one of
the best clean up facilities,
drug addiction facilities in the Bay area.
I got her at the top of the list,
because of a good reputation
I had for various things,
I got her at the top of the list.
I arranged with another
person, 'cause I wasn't
going to drive her myself, I
arranged with another person
to go and pick her up and to
take her immediately there
for when she was going to be discharged.
I went to the hospital, I was
elated, I thought this is it,
I'm going to make a change
in this girl's life,
you probably can anticipate what happened,
I got there and she had walked.
And her pimp had come in
early in the wee hours
of the morning, and escorted her out.
It is so disheartening and
that's just one incident,
you have had hundreds
and hundreds like this,
how do you keep going?
- Well to me, what I'm doing is not about,
I mean it sounds cold,
but I'm not about helping
these individuals, I've
helped more than my share,
as you've mentioned I've
spent well over $100,000
helping so and so and doing things exactly
like what you've described
and that costs money.
You put somebody up in a
hotel for a few months,
that adds up, when you want
to get them transportation
to go wherever they're
going, the money that I bleed
doing this is insane, it's embarrassing,
my accountant goes, "What
the hell are you doing?"
'cause I'm not getting receipts for any,
for most of what I'm doing
there are no receipts.
But rather than saying, I'm
gonna help each and every
individual of the 2000
that I've interviewed,
I can't do that.
One person, can't do that.
But honestly what I'm trying to do,
is help people understand,
have some awareness
and see what's really going on,
and see how these things happen,
so that we can prevent it
for the next generation.
I mean, what's that great quote?
It's easier to raise strong children,
than to repair broken men.
Frederick Douglas quote.
- Yes, good quote.
- It's a great quote, because
you wanna fix these people,
the problem is not that
they have a drug addiction,
it looks like all these
people are drug addicts,
or they're sex work addicts,
or they're gang members,
or whatever, the problem
is that they never were
loved as children.
They never experienced unconditional love
and that is the problem,
'cause you fix the addiction,
you give them a house,
you give them a car,
you give them a job, you give
them everything they need,
and they'll be back to where they started,
because they still are
trying to numb the pain
of never being loved.
The way to fix that is prevent it
from happening to the next generation.
- When you're dealing with people
who are clearly delusional,
I'm thinking of Sweet Pea
I'll play a clip from Sweet Pea.
- It's my first time for having a pimp,
a financial advisor whatever,
I give him all my money.
Whatever I need, he gets it for me,
so yeah, I wouldn't be doing it at all
if I didn't have my pimp, or my daddy.
Making money is making
money at the end of day
you look at it, I mean
I'm in love with my pimp
I do love him.
- She speaks of her pimp as
being her financial advisor.
- Yeah they all call
themselves financial advisors.
- And her pimp is her daddy pimp.
It's very interesting
usage of professional lingo
for financial advisor and
then familial terminology
for her daddy pimp, when very
often daddy in real life,
was the problem.
Do you ever just want to say to people,
okay listen to what
you're saying sweetheart,
listen to the incongruency
of what you're saying.
- Well I did that, I usually don't,
but I did that a little
bit on that interview,
just 'cause she was so closed off to-
- Reality.
- Being aware
of what she was doing and not looking at,
so I got a little bit judgemental,
which I've never really done on my videos
but I kind did a little
bit of that on that,
just 'cause she's asking for it,
she's so in denial of
anything that she was doing,
I mean she's got a kid,
she's addicted to drugs,
fentanyl I think it was.
- Yes.
- And she's got a pimp that
she's been in love with
for two weeks and he's
managing her money, 100% of it
and it's like oh come on,
everything is wrong here.
I think I said something,
kind of indicating
can you not look at this
and see it more clearly?
But she can't.
- I'd like to talk about the artistry,
because I think we would
be remiss if we don't
acknowledge the artistry to what you do.
You have developed an aesthetic,
the opening is we hear
street sounds very often,
ambient street sounds,
then we hear a voice
of the person who's
about to be interviewed,
then you dissolve into a
title, black and white,
white over black and
then it dissolves again
and we have a color image
of somebody speaking
and then eventually at
some strategic point,
you would then go to your
portrait that you've done.
You typically will start at the top,
with the face and you basically tilt down,
I presume you've taken the picture
with a large format camera.
- Yep.
- And then you tilt down
so you can get the
clarity 'cause you can't
do a horizontal plane, but it works,
and it's an aesthetic that
the viewer comes to expect.
Did that come innately to you,
or is it something premeditated?
- It's really just a terrible compromise,
'cause I'm shooting these
very vertical portraits,
I had a nine by 13 inch
camera custom made,
so it was basically to
accommodate the shape
of the human body, the dimensions,
the height versus the width.
And there is no way on social media,
which is our new world now
to display a tall vertical.
- Yes.
- Instagram is basically square
and so is everything else
and YouTube is horizontal and
since I'm doing interviews now
and videos, those are horizontal
so how do you fit a long,
almost extremely long vertical
into a horizontal format.
- Right.
- You just don't.
Put it sideways, (chuckling)
so the best thing
I could come up with is
this terrible compromise
where I pan down the portrait,
I cringe every time I do it,
but there is no other way.
- But I think it's a good effect,
because very often, I mean
I'm not trying to be unkind
I'm just being realistic as you are,
very often you'll see significant details
as you begin to tilt
down, you begin to notice
scabs and cuts and dirty toenails.
- The concept behind all of this,
is to have an inter shot
in such a large resolution
that my idea was to print
12 or 15 foot tall portraits
in a gigantic space and
then have a large TV monitor
playing the video alongside
that giant portrait.
So the portrait is really the star,
the portrait is what these
are really all about,
and the video is just a
supplement to the portrait,
but I think what people have
gotten used to on YouTube
is that the interview's everything
and the portraits disposable,
you don't have to look at it,
I've seen people comment,
"what's that stupid portrait
"in there for?"
To me it's really about the portrait,
and the video is just
kind like a backstory
to the portrait.
- You did a self disclosure video,
in fact you may have done
two, but I've certainly
seen one where you explain
what the whole premise
behind Soft White Underbelly is,
I notice that you seemed
uncomfortable Mark,
if I pointed out, looking
at the camera directly
you would do it sporadically
but most of the time
your eyes would wander around your studio
and then you would-
- Yeah I'm not a, I don't like
being in front of the camera,
it's not my thing.
- And why's that, why don't you?
- I have two daughters, one is like me,
really uncomfortable in front of a camera
and the other one she's meant,
my mom was a model, my
ex-wife was a model,
so she has it in her
blood and she's certainly
picked up those genes and she's just
amazing in front of a camera.
Like every frame is beautiful
and my other daughter
is the opposite of that
she takes after me, I'm
just not comfortable
in front of the camera.
But I got through it.
- Mark Laita, I'm very
cognizant of obviously Americans
in America and that's
why this show is called
Watching America, but
I'm incredibly intrigued
and rewarded when I
think about the persons
that make the fabric of this nation,
particularly persons who do important work
and you do important work.
I am so grateful to you
for presenting Jerry to me
and millions of other viewers
and persons like Jerry, Sarah
for all of her complexity,
Kiara or Kelly whichever you prefer,
Sweet Pea and hundreds and
hundreds of people more,
you strike me as a
person who's not at ease
perhaps with praise or being
lauded with recognition,
but I hope that you'll amend
that for the next 10 seconds
as I say, that I think
you are truly an artist
and your life has purpose and
meaning in it's own right,
but beyond that, for what you do
and what you're bringing
to America's attention.
We may not have an immediate kind of seer
for what you portray and present to us,
but indeed you do awaken things in us,
that otherwise should
not have gone un-awoken
and I want to thank you for that so much.
It's been a delight talking to you Mark.
- My pleasure, thank you so much.
- Take care sir and God bless.
- Thank you Alan, bye bye.
- [Woman] Watching America
is is a production of WHRV
public media in Norfolk, Virginia.